Sleeping naked is supposed to have all kinds
of benefits, so being naked all the time can
only be more awesome, right? ...that’s not
how it works? ...awkward...
Hey guys, a fully clothed Amy with you on
DNews today.
To get to the meat of why sleeping naked might
be good for you, we have to look at the one
undeniable fact about nudity: When you have
no clothes on, you stay cooler, and that is
really what sleeping naked is all about.
There's a fair bit of research out there that
says being cooler not only helps you fall
asleep but also helps you sleep deeper without
waking up during the night.
And it’s not just a comfort thing. Being
cooler has to do with neural activity. In
both humans and animals, warmer skin has been
linked to increased activity in areas of the
brain that regulate sleep cycles; the warmer
the subject the more disturbed their sleep.
One study from the journal “Brain” found
that a moderate cooling of the skin, just
1.08ºF, helped subjects sleep more deeply
and stopped them waking up at night, particularly
the elderly.
Another study from the University of South
Australia looked deeper into the body, literally,
and found that lowering people’s core temperatures
was vital in getting patients to fall asleep
faster.
And once you’re asleep in the nude, there
are health benefits! Sleeping naked allows
your skin to breathe, and also your private
area. This can be especially important for
women, particularly those prone to yeast infections.
Because bacteria, including yeast, thrive
in warm, moist areas, freeing your lady bits
from constricting fabric and allowing it to
breathe all night can decrease bad bacterial
growth and help prevent infections.
And while there’s not really a male equivalent,
some men prefer to sleep naked to keep their
testicles cooler and improve their sperm count,
particularly if they're trying for kids.
And speaking of kids, another benefit to sleeping
naked? Adult time! Skin to skin contact, particularly
with someone you're into, is a powerful form
of mind-body medicine. Touching, like hugging,
releases oxytocin, a hormone that makes us
feel secure. It also lowers cortisol levels,
which boosts the immune system, and can lower
blood pressure and heart rate. And as we know,
and science confirms, sex involves at least
some parts of you being naked.
And of course, good sleep is crucial for your
whole body, not just for feeling rested in
the morning! Sleep is a time when a lot of
important hormones are released into the bloodstream,
managing our appetites, helping maintain a
healthy immune system, and repairing skin
tissues. So really, cool sleep is beauty sleep.
But ultimately, if you're not comfortable
sleeping naked, you might not sleep well.
So if you're a clothed sleeper, try setting
the thermostat a little lower for the same
benefits.
So, what about my whole “being naked all
the time” experiment? I’m not wrong! Trace
gets into the benefits of more naked time
in this video right here.
So, be honest guys, who out there sleeps naked?
Let us know in the comments, don’t forget
to like this video, and subscribe for a new
episode of DNews every day of the week.